[Music]
straight ahead all on crime daily
brittany griner pleads guilty in russia
as united states works to secure her
release and the penalty phase will soon
begin for the parkland school shooter
there is no good other explanation for
using a nazi symbol to be able to
display at the time where you've just
murdered 17 people and
wounded 17 others what evidence defense
attorneys want excluded from the coming
trial plus after weeks as a fugitive
from the law and an illegal flight out
of the country a texas woman is charged
in the murder of a professional cyclist
mo wilson and later the murder of nipsy
hustle the people of the state of
california versus eric ronald holder jr
we the jury find the defendant guilty of
the crime of first degree murder a
california jury seals the fate of
defendant eric holder law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmart american
basketball star brittany griner pleads
guilty to drug charges in russia five
months after she's detained overseas
this comes as news circulates that the
united states may exchange griner for
russian arms dealer victor bout who was
sentenced to 25 years in a united states
federal prison in 2012. greiner's
russian trial began last friday months
after she was arrested at a russian
airport when less than a gram of
cannabis oil was allegedly discovered in
her luggage while griner pled guilty to
the charges she denies that she
intentionally broke the law griner
indicated she plans to testify in the
trial but says she needs time to prepare
a russian judge previously ordered
greiner remain in the country until the
trial is concluded if convicted she
faces 10 years behind bars but in the
back in the united states president
biden received a handwritten letter from
griner urging him not to forget her
after this president biden spoke with
greiner's wife saying he is working to
secure her release at the same time the
kremlin is accused of using griner as a
political pawn while the united states
maintains she was wrongfully detained
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney nima romani and co-host terry
austin nemo greiner has pled guilty but
she said but says she didn't intend to
pack the less than one gram of cannabis
oil in her bag could that help her in
sentencing
yes it can obviously this case is
entirely political right i mean there's
no question that russia is retaliating
for the u.s support of ukraine and
trying to gain leverage in some sort of
prisoner swap but turning to the legal
aspect of it russian law is interesting
in that even if you plead you still go
to trial so this is a mitigation play
obviously 10 years is way too high for
possession of a small amount of drugs in
any country so i think that's what
brittany's trying to do here play the
mitigation card not actually try to
defend the case on the merits turns out
she's doing what we would call here an
alford plea basically saying hey i'm not
going to contest the charges but i'm not
going to defend them either yeah terry
do you think the united states should
participate in negotiations for the
release of prisoners in russia and
around the world
absolutely you know obviously our
president is given the power under
article 2 of the constitution and those
powers include the right to negotiate he
also obviously is the commander-in-chief
he signs bills into law but that
negotiation right to talk about what's
going on in our country and foreign
countries includes making sure he can
negotiate the release of prisoners he's
done this before in april he just
negotiated the release of trevor reid
who was a u.s marine he could very well
do the same thing you mentioned victor
about and perhaps we could get brittany
griner out with the release of victor
bout but i will say that i think that he
should be looking at other people too
and i think he is just because brittany
griner is very famous he should also
look at people who are not as famous and
hopefully he will do that and that
includes paul whalen who is also a u.s
marine and he is imprisoned there so
hopefully he can get
multiple people out of russia absolutely
and in hopes that as you said both
whelan and greiner can come back home
safely
and in colorado jurors hear from the
medical examiner in the double murder
trial of kevin dean eastman as he faces
charges in the deaths of his
ex-girlfriend and her new lover
eastman is charged with two counts of
first-degree murder tampering with a
deceased body and tampering with
physical evidence authorities say
eastman killed his ex-girlfriend heather
frank and local greely colorado musician
stanley scott sessions on separate days
in february of 2020 and what prosecutors
say appears to have been a love triangle
eastman previously told investigators he
went to frank's apartment to talk about
getting back together but she told him
to leave because she had a date at a
preliminary hearing months after the
deaths prosecutors called the
throat-slitting killing of sessions an
ambush and that eastman fatally shot
frank to silence the only witness to
sessions murder before frank's body was
found she and eastman both had arrest
warrants in connection to sessions
murder investigators say eastman also
burned session's body and allegedly was
preparing to burn frank's body when law
enforcement arrested him at a gas
station the medical examiner testified
wednesday sharing the graphic details of
sessions fatal injuries
for mr sessions one of your diagnosis
was sharp force injury to the the neck
and head is that right yes
tell the jury with regard to this
picture
what you're talking about when you talk
about a sharp force injury to the neck
and head in this photograph you can see
that his neck has
been cut here kind of superficially just
to the muscle
and then here much deeper
so that is that is a sharp force injury
to the neck that we described
this is um from i think the back of the
head that's correct
and it should okay go ahead i think that
might give you a better way to it shows
how how deep this
wound is on the side in the back of the
neck it actually goes
to the
the
vertebrae the cervical bone
in the center of the neck what kind of
force
has to be applied in order to
create this type of it would depend on
the
the
sharpness of the knife
um
i don't i can't give you a numeric
designation but
it would it would require a steady
pretty hard
cut
still ahead on law and crime daily after
more than 40 days on the run a texas
woman is charged in the death of a
professional cyclist but first the
parkland school shooter's coming penalty
phase what defense attorneys want
excluded from the trial
[Music]
welcome back defense attorneys for the
parkland school shooter want to exclude
his past use of swastikas racial slurs
and animal abuse at the coming penalty
phase for their client back in 2018 the
gunman opened fire at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in parkland florida
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured last october the gunman pled
guilty to all charges after a lengthy
jury selection and multiple delays the
upcoming death penalty trial is expected
to begin on july 18th at a hearing on
wednesday defense attorneys work to
exclude portions of the shooter's pass
from the coming trial prosecutors say a
swastika was etched on the ar-15 used in
the shooting and also on the shooter's
boots on top of that he had a racial
slur on his backpack his internet
history showed searches for mass
killings child pornography and animal
abuse at wednesday's hearing a forensic
psychologist testified that some of the
shooter's actions support a mental
health diagnosis
what evidence
do you have that he
was indifferent to or rationalizing
having
done this to hurt someone else there is
no good other explanation for using a
nazi symbol to be able to display at the
time where you've just murdered 17
people and
wounded 17 others and leaving that on an
open display for people to see to cause
an emotional reaction in them
and to have a lack of feeling or content
about how those people might react in
some way and feel badly about what their
reactions might be just not about
shooting and killing people but also in
seeing that kind of a symbol i think
there's no better example except in his
other social media posts about lack of
remorse and guilt
okay so
you're
assuming that because he put it on there
when he went to commit this crime and
left it there that that was a conscious
decision to further
hurt people
when it was found i think it's
i'm sorry
i think it's attention seeking but i
think that to not appreciate the impact
that and other images and other words
might have i think that's a hallmark of
anti-social personality disorder so i'd
say in totality the social media posts
including the swastikas and how he's
chosen to use those and what he's spoken
to people about in those media posts i
think is a very important
opening of the window into his brain
about how he thinks about these images
and his lack of ability to show empathy
and remorse
right now there's no word when judge
elizabeth will make a ruling on the
defense's motion
terry how do you think the judge will
rule on the defense motion to exclude
this type of evidence
you know the whole question obviously in
all of these evidentiary questions is
what's more probative or prejudicial and
i think he's going to look individually
at each and every piece of evidence so
for instance on the racial slur and the
internet searches for mass killings on
the swasticas i do think the judge is
going to say that's probative and look
we're looking here at whether it's life
or death and i do think those are
aggravating circumstances as for the
child pornography the animal abuse i
think the judge is going to say that's
not really relevant and so perhaps that
will stay out so i think it'll be a
split motion president those are kind of
the standards that terry have laid out
for us but whose argument for including
or excluding evidence seems more
persuasive to you
the states brian and that's not just
because i'm a former federal prosecutor
look judges have a lot more leeway in
the penalty phase we know the defense is
going to bring in everything right
cruz's alleged fetal alcohol syndrome we
talked about you know his anti-social
personality sort of borderline
personalities or the fact that he was
bullied maybe rejected by a girl all
this is going to come in in mitigation
but the state has to prove an
aggravating factor and they got to prove
it unanimously if even one juror
disagrees they're not going to get a
death sentence so i think the swastikas
i think the racial slurs where he said
he wants to kill as many black people as
possible and other evidence let's not
forget he attacked a prison guard while
he was in custody in this case it's all
going to come in it's all relevant so i
think the state has the better argument
here yeah i would agree as well but i
also kind of agree with terry only on
that one part of the child abuse and the
child pornography i'm not sure if that
comes in but i think everything else
does of course we'll continue with
reporting and giving you those updates
as to what evidence does and doesn't
come into the parkland school shooter
case
and the trial for the parkland school
resource officer scott peterson is
delayed due to potential witness
complications the former broward county
sheriff's deputy was the school resource
officer at the marjory stoneman douglas
high school at the time of the parkland
school shooting after the incident he
was criticized fired and eventually
charged for failing to confront the
parkland school shooter before he killed
17 and wounded 17 others the judge
thursday said his trial should be
delayed as to not have both his and the
parkland school shooters trials going at
the same time which could cause
conflicts with crossover witnesses his
trial was set for september the parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial is
expected to last through october
peterson faces child neglect culpable
negligence and perjury charges if
convicted he faces a max sentence of
nearly a hundred years the former
deputy's trial is now set for february
of 2023
coming up on law and crime daily a
verdict is handed down for the man
charged in the murder of nifty hustle
plus the love triangle captivating the
nation we head to texas where a woman is
finally charged in the murder of a
professional cyclist
[Music]
welcome back after more than 40 days on
the run overseas yoga teacher caitlin
armstrong is charged with the murder of
professional cyclist mo wilson 34 year
old armstrong was arrested in costa rica
on june 29th after investigators say she
fled the country for her involvement in
wilson's death wilson whose real name is
anna mariah was shot and killed on may
11th investigators say she may have
dated caitlyn armstrong's boyfriend
while the two were on a break though the
boyfriend maintains it was a platonic
relationship after texas authorities
questioned armstrong she sold her
vehicle to a dealership and boarded a
plane investigators believe armstrong
used her sister's passport to leave the
country and fly to costa rica once there
armstrong altered her appearance by
dyeing her hair and undergoing cosmetic
surgery after her arrest in costa rica
armstrong was sent back to the united
states and booked into the travis county
jail in austin texas she's being held on
three and a half million dollar bond
terry the current bond is extremely high
but
should there be any bonds said in this
case at all
you know brian there are certain types
of cases in my opinion where no amount
of bond would have been sufficient i
think she should have gotten no bond she
should have been remanded straight to
prison she's clearly not a threat of
society so i don't think that's the
issue but i do think she's a flight risk
obviously she fled to costa rica she
changed her appearance so much so that
she got surgery i mean obviously dying
her hair she used her sister's identity
all of these things show that she will
go to great lengths to hide to run to
not face charges so if she did it once i
think she'd do it again and i think the
court would have been justified in
saying no no bond at all now the good
news is it's such a high amount i don't
think it will ever be met and i think
she will remain in jail until the case
is tried yeah neima i'm sure you've had
that situation we say your honor my
client's not a flight risk and the judge
is like she literally flew out of the
country the bond makes sense there in
some sense nemo i'm struggling to see
both sides of this potential trial here
is there a defense here or do you think
the defense attorneys are merely just
looking for the best plea either way
what can they argue in her favor
yeah there's really no defense here
right it's just a case about you know
getting the best possible deal avoiding
a life sentence getting some mitigation
she's obviously very young because
armstrong's in for a world of hurt here
not just state
prison state murder charges and which
will likely get her in state prison
there's a federal hold as well so this
one was rare cases where the feds may
come after obviously u.s marshals had to
track her down another country get her
extradited so this is not a defensible
case hopefully if you're the her lawyers
you can come up with some of some global
resolution to get her out of prison
hopefully in 20 25 years that's the best
it's going to get for her yeah there's a
reason why they call it pleading because
she might do a lot of pleading in this
case to try to get the best offer
possible if that's even open to her well
when we come back a jury's decision is
handed down in california in the case of
eric holder as he's tried for the murder
of rapper nifty hustle
[Music]
welcome back reality tv star jerry
harris of the netflix show cheer is
sentenced to 12 years in federal prison
for sex crimes involving children the
sentence was handed down on wednesday in
september of 2020 harris was arrested on
charges in the production of child
pornography and for soliciting sex and
sexually explicit images for minors in
february of this year he pled guilty to
charges of child pornography and
crossing state lines to engage in sex
with a child harris admitted to
exchanging sexual images with upwards of
15 children in three different states
harris admitted he knew the children
were under age at the time while
harris's team argues for a six-year
sentence prosecutors advocated for a
15-year sentence in the end a federal
judge handed down a 12-year sentence
with eight years of supervised release
the judge noted harris used his
celebrity status and wealth to
manipulate and exploit children and a
man on trial in the for killing
california rapper nipsey hussell faces a
sentence of life in prison after a jury
convicted eric holder junior of first
degree murder this week
thirty-three-year-old nipsey hassell was
shot and killed in march of 2019 in
front of the rapper's marathon clothing
store in los angeles his accused killer
finally faced a jury trial after three
years of delays prosecutors say holders
shot nipsey hussle after the two men got
into a dispute when the rapper accused
him of being a snitch a medical examiner
found the rapper was shot at least 10
times with the bullets piercing his
lungs and severing his spinal cord after
less than two days of deliberations on
wednesday a jury found holder jr guilty
of first degree murder attempted murder
and assault with a deadly weapon his
defense attorney argued throughout the
trial that his client didn't deny
shooting nipsey hustle only that the
fatal shooting wasn't premeditated
wednesday afternoon the clerk read the
jury's decision before the court
sir please read the words
in the superior court of california
county of los angeles department 104
the people of the state of california
versus eric ronald holder jr
case number ba 475908
we the jury in the above entitled action
find the defendant eric ronald holder jr
guilty of the crime of first degree
murder of irmius ashkedong
in violation of penal code section
187 subsection a a felony as charged in
count one of the indictment
all right that's the best part about law
and crime daily i get to ask an la
lawyer about an la case so who better
than nemo to ask nima the murder charge
for nipsey hustle that seems like a slam
dunk easy to figure out for the
prosecutor but for the two bystanders
holder junior shot he was charged with
attempted murder but he was convicted of
voluntary manslaughter why do you think
that was
it's an inconsistent verdict brian
because holder's defense was that nipsy
hustle called him a snitch and that
provoked him such that you know a
reasonable person would have acted the
way he did kind of like when you walk in
on your significant other in bed with
someone else you go into that blind rage
well the jury said that no it was
premeditated with respect to nipsy
hustle he went back got a gun there's
several minutes had passed but it was
provoked sufficiently with respect to
the other two not gonna matter because
the judge wasn't gonna run the sentences
consecutively anyway it would be
concurrent sentence but it doesn't make
sense where you find that one was
sufficiently provoked but one was or two
weren't so yeah maybe he was trying to
hit nipsey but those two people just
happened to be there i don't know but
that's what the jury came up with terry
you were working in la when nipsey
hussle was shot and you saw the reaction
in the community how do you think the
community will respond to this
conviction
brian you're right that reaction at the
time of the shooting was severe it was
substantial and at the time i was
actually teaching and we couldn't talk
about anything else that entire day
because these kids who were in their
early 20s really were affected by this
you have to remember that hustle rose
above his circumstances he started out
as a gang member actually the same gang
that eric holder jr was in but he became
a rapper he actually was grammy
nominated and he was an inspiration to
his community he bought property he
opened businesses he hired people he
gave others an opportunity the same type
of opportunity he actually didn't have
so he was well loved and i think this
verdict is going to help
absolutely well thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on lawn and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you